voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité du Sénat au gouvernement et
on va commencer par aller réactions
après cette séance je me trouve avec
Christophe Béchu le ministre de la
transition écologique bonjour bonjour on
a attendu cet après-midi des sénateurs
inquiets notamment par la situation de
notre transport du quotidien de nos
trains du quotidien mais également une
autre inquiétude qui est grande et qui
concerne ce qu'on appelle les aides les
zones à faible émission ça veut dire que
progressivement dans les années à venir
et bien elle est véhicules polluants
vont être interdits dans les grandes
agglomérations Christophe Béchu est-ce
que vous ne craignez pas une nouvelle
crise des gilets jaunes une nouvelle
explosion sociale d'abord il faut qu'on
rappelle pourquoi on le fait il y a
47000 morts en France à cause de la
pollution atmosphérique à cause du
dioxyde à cause des des particules fines
et ces concentrations elles sont où
elles sont dans les endroits qui sont
les plus urbains le sujet du
gouvernement c'est pas d'emmerder les
Français c'est pas de chercher une
nouvelle lubie pour faire en sorte de
les ennuyer c'est de préserver de
protéger les plus fragiles les personnes
âgées les enfants qui vivent dans ces
villes et on va pas installer comme je
le lis des radars
il y a des outils qu'on met à la
disposition des mers qui ont la
responsabilité de faire en sorte de
respecter les seuils qui ont été fixés
par l'OMS et par les institutions
nationales et donc on a lancé hier un
groupe de travail avec tous les maires
qui sont concernés pour qu'au contraire
on partage des questions pour qu'on
partage des inquiétudes dans les
inquiétudes il y a la question sociale
celle de l'accessibilité comment on fait
pour que les plus pauvres qui se
retrouvent parfois avec les voitures les
plus vieilles précisément ils soient pas
exclus parce que le centre-ville c'est
l'hôpital c'est parfois les services
publics et donc toute la réflexion c'est
comment en termes de qualité de l'air on
protège les Français sans le faire au
détriment des plus fragiles et c'est ce
qui explique la concertation le fait que
il n'y aura pas de radar avant au moins
deux ans certains d'ailleurs disent que
ça va pas assez vite il y aura des
radars à l'entrée de Séville non il y
aura la possibilité pour les mères qu'il
souhaite d'acquérir des radars dont on
va établir la typologie dans les années
qui viennent et pour être très clair un
des sujets qu'on a évoqué hier c'est et
ce qui peut pas y avoir aussi des
dérogations qui sont permanentes pour
des dérouleur est-ce qu'on peut pas
imaginer qu'il y a un certain nombre de
fois dans l'année on peut se rendre
parce qu'en parallèle il faut qu'il y
ait des alternatives le sujet c'est
aussi d'avoir des véhicules qui soient
moins polluants aujourd'hui ces
véhicules électriques ou hybrides ils
sont très chers on a beau mettre en
place des aides on voit bien que c'est
pas forcément évident compte tenu des
restes à payer donc on fait en sorte de
les améliorer il y a un prêt à taux zéro
qui va entrer en vigueur dans quelques
jours il y a un garantie de l'État on va
l'élargir à ceux qui gardent la voiture
mais qui changent le moteur on va faire
en sorte de garantir aussi des aides
pour ceux qui font des achats d'occasion
mais plus le temps va passer plus on
aura des véhicules d'occasion peu
polluants donc vous devez donc deux
trois ans le parc de véhicules
électriques sera assez suffisant pour
pouvoir et bien mettre en place ces
zones affaiblissement
la qualité de l'air la protection de la
santé des Français on ne transige pas
avec en parallèle on le fait pas
n'importe comment on rétablit pas des
péages à l'entrée des villes on
construit un dispositif national chaque
ville aura ensuite à le mettre en place
à déterminer les amplitudes les horaires
et en parallèle on aide les Français qui
sont concernés par les plus vieux
véhicules en acquérir de nouveau pas
seulement des neufs parce qu'en terme de
transition écologique il faut aussi
éviter seulement de construire des
véhicules neufs faut regarder comment on
les change et comment on peut trouver
des véhicules d'occasion abordables et
propres et ça il y a besoin d'un peu de
temps est-ce que vous avez évalué le
nombre de véhicules qui pourraient être
interdit de l'entrée dans ces
agglomérations ça représente des
millions de voitures chaque année le
parc se renouvelle les véhicules les
plus polluants sortent des véhicules
plus
respectueux de l'environnement entre
l'année prochaine l'année dernière
pardon c'est 11% des véhicules qui
étaient électriques ou hybrides les
projections qu'on a c'est que ce chiffre
il devrait peut-être quasiment doublé
cette année faire en sorte de se
prolonger donc on voit cette tendance
en parallèle il faut bien mesurer qu'il
n'y a que 43 agglomérations en France
qui sont concernés que dans les 43 il
n'y en a que 10 à l'heure actuelle qui
ont mis en place ce type de zone et que
entre Paris Lyon Marseille il y a déjà
des règles qui sont pas les mêmes
Marseille s'adapte il y a deux mois on
est uniquement sur les très vieux
véhicules qui ont plus de 25 ans Paris
on a déjà un peu plus de recul et donc
les degrés de restriction ne sont d'ores
et déjà pas les mêmes il faut y aller de
façon déterminée parce que c'est un
enjeu de santé publique mais il faut y
aller une manière progressive pour
éviter des explosions sociales ou pour
éviter des difficultés tout court et
tenir les deux en même temps ça
nécessite de la nuance et la nuance
parfois en politique c'est pas ce qu'il
y a de plus simple à défendre c'est
difficile en politique merci beaucoup
Chris merci d'avoir répondu à mes
questions
[Musique]